i
ah
peregrinación a la meca el gs es uno de
los cinco pilares del islam y según
establece el coral los musulmanes están
obligados a hacerlo al menos una vez en
la vida si pueden y tienen recursos para
ello concretamente la peregrinación se
da entre el día 8 y 10 de dhul y este
mes que es el último del calendario
islámico y en ella los musulmanes
entregan el tawakkul su confianza plena
en dios uno de los rituales principales
es dar siete vueltas alrededor de la
kaaba que es una construcción que hay en
medio de la gran mezquita y el recorrido
representa la distancia entre las
montañas sagradas de safa
marwa también se visitan otros lugares
sagrados y se completan los rituales
espirituales y alejadas culmina con la
ida la upl aquí en marruecos se celebra
hoy es el día en que muchas familias se
sacrifican un cordero y reparten la
carne entre seres queridos y personas
más necesitadas y para hacer el hash se
requiere un visado de arabia saudi cada
año otorgan un número de visados en
función de los musulmanes que allí se
postulan en cada país anteriormente a la
pandemia desde aquí salían más de 20.000
personas al cada año que se ganaban el
sorteo pero hasta ahora los viajes
siguen restringidos
[Música]
i
por segundo año consecutivo desde que se
inició la pandemia los egipcios se
quedarán sin peregrinar a la meca sólo
aquellos que vivan y sean residentes en
arabia saudi podrán hacerlo si han sido
seleccionados entre esos 60 mil que las
autoridades saudíes han escogido de
todos aquellos que se presentaron a
través de una página web solicitando
acudir para cumplir con uno de esos
cinco pilares del islam la preceptiva
visita a la meca que todo musulmán
debería realizar al menos una vez en la
vida 35 mil 500 egipcios lo hicieron en
2019 justo antes de iniciarse la
pandemia así que una vez más este año
los egipcios se tendrán que conformarse
con hacerlo en casa en la celebración
del aid el adha a la fiesta del
sacrificio del cordero que todos los
años celebran conmemorando aquel momento
en el que el profeta abraham quiso
sacrificar a su propio hijo ante dios lo
hacen sacrificando corderos y otros
animales y compartiendo los con los más
pobres pero también con sus familias
[Música]
durante los años normales previos a la
crisis de el coronavirus cerca de 80 mil
peregrinos salían desde turquía cada año
para realizar el hash cómo se llama la
peregrinación anual a la meca sin
embargo durante esta crisis el
coronavirus la peregrinación ha sido
prohibida en turquía el gobierno que es
quien organiza esta peregrinación ha
cancelado los visados para este año y
los ha pospuesto para el año siguiente
en turquía ocurre algo que ocurre en
pocos países del mundo y es que hay un
ministerio de asuntos religiosos que
controla al dedillo todo lo que ocurre
con la religión es una herencia que
tiene turquía desde los años de la
república secular de mustafa kemal
atatürk todo asunto religioso que ocurre
en turquía ocurre bajo los auspicios del
gobierno sin embargo estas fiestas del
eid al-adha hawk como se llaman en
turquía curvan bagram y son muy
distintas en el país la mayoría de las
personas viaja a los pueblos
para rendir homenaje y visitar a los
abuelos o padres en los pueblos por eso
ciudades grandes como esta mundo nos
encontramos ahora mismo están
completamente vacías durante una semana
entera